the first immunizations with the newly
approved astrazeneca vaccine are
underway the shot was developed in
cooperation with oxford university
and british pharmaceutical company
astrazeneca it could prove to have an
edge for some countries struggling to
deploy mass immunizations
the shot is less expensive and it's also
easier to store
many experts believe these qualities
could make the latest vaccine more
accessible for developing countries in
particular
and let's get some perspective on the
story now we have mohammed munir with us
he's a
virologist at lancaster university in
england good to have you back with us
how significant is the rollout of this
vaccine in particular
well uh so if we look really on to the
number of cases those are surging very
uh significantly in the uk
particularly because of the festive
season and also the new variant and we
are heading toward the winter
so all in all uh situation is is is
pretty grim
and i think the only way we can really
get this whole scenario in control is to
have a mass vaccination
and that is not the priority in the uk
to have as many people as possible
to humanize and the government is
planning to have at least 30 million
people above
55 years old including frontline
health workers care homes to be
vaccinated until the easter time
okay so this vaccine is cheaper it is
easier to store but what about its
safety and efficacy i mean was it the
right decision by the government there
in the uk
to rush to start this as the first
country in the world
well that is something is pretty
debatable the reason is that we have the
data that was published in the very
reputable journal the launch
journal but that data isn't really the
one that made the basis for the approval
of this vaccine the data that made the
approval
for this vaccine is only belonging to
the government that is not publicly
available and according to the
government
is like this that if the first dose is
given the pers
there is around 70 efficacy and then if
it is
uh the second dose given then it would
be around 80 percent efficacy with the
interval of uh
three months but but that is something
that we haven't seen the data so
therefore
all is in air and we don't really know
how efficacious would it be particularly
after the first doze
okay that is important to know and
there's another question muhammad
reports now that the british government
is
worried that this will not be as
effective against the south african
variant of the virus tell us about that
yes south african variant emerged before
the
uk uh new variant emerged and both of
these variant emerged independently
there isn't any link except that there
are a few mutations those are common
and we have noticed that south africa
has been the worst hit country
in the whole africa um with the highest
number of deaths and the infection per
capita
so therefore this is certainly worrying
and whenever when we come to
new variant of course we at the moment
we don't have a data that will escape
the immunity established by the vaccine
but we can't simply ignore that all
these variant could
jeopardize not only the vaccine campaign
but also the uh
the restrictions those been put in place
because of their transmissibility so
certainly
these are the things that need to be
looked very carefully in coming days
mohammed monir virologist from lancaster
university in england as always good to
talk to you
germany's build newspaper and the
reuters news agency are reporting that
chancellor merkel's government
and regional leaders have agreed to
extend germany's lockdown until the end
of january
that's ahead of a planned meeting
tomorrow between the chancellor and
16 regional leaders weeks of tougher
restrictions on public life have
so far failed to effectively bring down
infection rates
and the country's vaccination program
has gotten off to a sluggish start
appeals to stay home seem to have little
effect in this western german winter
resort town
a ban on entering the ski runs failed to
deter large numbers of people from
hitting the slopes at the weekend so
many that
police intervened stopping winter
enthusiasts
in their tracks germany's government
together with the heads of its regional
states
must decide on how to proceed with
anti-coronavirus measures
there's consensus that a lockdown will
have to remain in place beyond
january 10th bavaria wants it extended
by at least
three more weeks the numbers are still
too high and we're not yet able to
assess how the situation has developed
over christmas
new year and especially through the
large numbers of travellers returning
home
that's why it would be irresponsible to
relax the lockdown now
it should be extended until the end of
january
on tuesday state heads will discuss how
long the lockdown should be extended for
and whether the current measures should
be adjusted
states with lower infection numbers want
a shorter lockdown
while those harder hit want measures
toughened
we need to act in those areas that are
most affected
in this case that's saxony and thuringia
so we'll be toughening measures for our
schools and child care facilities until
january
31st just as we'll be doing with public
life will be increasing restrictions
even more
a key topic on the agenda is whether
nurseries and primary schools should be
closed
some argue that young children struggle
with online learning
but germany's central government remains
skeptical about whether physical
teaching in schools is a good idea
our political correspondent hans brandt
is tracking the very latest on this
story for us hi hans
we're seeing reports now that uh the
government of chancellor merkel is
indeed planning to
extend the current lockdown measures uh
what more can you tell us
well that's a further confirmation of
rumors and reports
that we've had for several days now
obviously before the meeting between
angela merkel and the 16 regional heads
preparatory discussions are ongoing and
i presume that this will be a leak from
those preparatory discussions
and it is intended to put those regional
states under pressure that might
consider not extending the lockdown for
as long as everybody else
seems to be thinking is correct until
the end of january
in the end the decision will be taken
tomorrow by angela merkel and the 16
regional leaders and those meetings have
in the past
taken hours have been at times
characterized by very acrimonious
debates
so there's no certainty yet that this
decision is going to be taken
even if the reports today uh propose
that
and this all comes amid a lot of
questions being asked about
chancellor america's government's
vaccine rollout and we have a
graphic rather that we can pull up to
show this the country that has
administered
the most doses per 100 people as you can
see here is
israel it's already vaccinated nearly 13
percent of its population
after that comes bahrain the uk then the
u.s and denmark rounding out the top
five but germany has vaccinated less
than
0.3 percent of its population that makes
it
ninth on the list so hans tell us more
about this criticism
of germany and why there's been a
sluggish start to vaccinating
the main criticism is that there is too
little vaccine available to make it
possible to
vaccinate as quickly as everybody would
like
that in fact is a problem at the moment
in the european union only one vaccine
is approved that is the one from
biontech a second vaccine may be
approved this
coming week so the number of doses that
are available to germany
of a vaccine that is contested around
the world
is comparatively small at the same time
there are some hiccups in
the organization of this vaccination
campaign inside germany
it's not as easy to get a vaccination
even if you're entitled to that
to it as it should be but at the same
time i think there is a sense of
uh kind of desperation from some regions
in germany
that the lockdown measures so far have
not worked very well
have not really pushed down the
infection rates and
that the last hope is this vaccination
so those regions that are particularly
badly affected such as bavaria and
southern germany for instance
are the ones that are pushing harder for
the vaccination program to
be pushed ahead to go more quickly to
give it an extra
push dw political correspondent hans
brunt thank you very much
let's take a look now at some other
developments in the pandemic
japan is considering a state of
emergency to slow the spread in greater
tokyo
that move raises more doubts about
whether tokyo will be able to host the
olympics
this summer south africa has announced a
plan to begin immunizations next month
pending a rival of
its first vaccines the country is the
worst hit on the continent
australia's most populous state new
south wales is reporting
zero local coronavirus cases that state
includes sydney where residents can be
fined on the spot if they don't wear
masks
in public